Speaker 1: We have not spoken about
Speaker 2: 08
Speaker 1: and for a while, OANN is one America
news, or sometimes it's 08 and one America
news network.
OANN is sort of the crazy uncle to Newsmax,
which is already like the crazy uncle to Fox
News.
Fox News is hard right wing propaganda.
Speaker 2: Newsmax is extreme
Speaker 1: right wing propaganda, and OANN
would sort of be like
Speaker 2: something even more insane.
I don't even know what
Speaker 1: it's crazier than Newsmax, with
even worse production value and anchors who
struggle even more, obviously to read the
teleprompter.
I want to call your attention to a segment
that aired yesterday on own.
This is a blend of globalist one.
Speaker 2: World government conspiracy
Speaker 1: theories combined with straight
up lies about how things work in the real
world.
The anti-vaccine absurdity has reached a new
level unknown.
Speaker 2: And in this clip, we're going to
hear from an anchor
Speaker 1: named Christina Bob.
Speaker 2: That's Bob with two BS
Speaker 1: at the end Bob.
She was visibly struggling to read the conspiracies
off of the teleprompter, the whole segment.
But the case she makes is that globalists
globalists, as Alex Jones would say, are getting
ready to scrap the Nuremberg code in Europe
in order to make COVID vaccines
Speaker 2: mandatory for all.
Speaker 1: Now there are, maybe we think,
one to those like six or seven layers of dishonesty
and confusion in this segment.
Let's look at the video.
Listen to the video.
You'll notice that compared to this drivel,
Newsmax almost seems measured if you can believe
it.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 3: COVID is about control and manipulating
our physical bodies through the vaccine, which
is one of the most humiliating and inhumane
ways to demoralize a person by depriving them
of control of their own bodies and subjecting
humans to medical experiments.
It's for that reason that the world created
the Nuremberg codes after World War Two.
We recognize that medical experiments, concentration
camps, mass murder and all the other atrocities
that occurred during the war were inhumane
and should never be tolerated again.
Yet the European Union leadership is now calling
for throwing out the Nuremberg code.
Ursula von der Leyen, the head of the European
Union Commission, has argued in favor of throwing
out the Nuremberg code, ignore it completely
and allow countries to force vaccinate anyone
refusing to participate in the medical experiment.
The globalists are going crazy and resorting
to crazy methodologies that most humans would
not agree with, like ignoring the Nuremberg
code.
Why?
Because they are losing.
It is a last resort to out themselves as the
evil, inhumane tyrants that they are.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, listen, let.
Let's just go line by line, right?
COVID is about controlling other people.
No, it's not.
COVID is a pandemic, and we're trying to get
out of it safe.
The vaccines manipulate our physical bodies.
This is along the lines of they change your
DNA.
They don't.
That's not true.
The vaccines are inhumane.
There is no scientific
Speaker 2: basis for that assertion.
Speaker 1: The vaccines are a medical experiment.
Speaker 2: No, they aren't.
They're approved by
Speaker 1: emergency use authorization and
the Pfizer vaccine
Speaker 2: as full FDA approval.
Speaker 1: And then we get into like the really
wacky stuff.
The Nuremberg codes were created to stop medical
experiments, she says.
Now that's true.
The Nuremberg codes were created after World
War Two,
Speaker 2: and it does relate to human experimentation.
Speaker 1: It just has no relevance to vaccines
that have been approved at all.
Speaker 2: The European Union is not calling
Speaker 1: for throwing out the Nuremberg
code, and this is like the Big Lie.
Ursula von der Leyen is the head of the European
Commission, and she recently said at a press
conference.
The European Union's member states should
encourage
Speaker 2: and they should think about making
vaccines mandatory.
Speaker 1: Not you have to make them mandatory
member states, meaning countries like Belgium,
France, etc. they should think about mandatory
vaccination.
She didn't mention the Nuremberg code.
She said nothing about scrapping the Nuremberg
code.
She said nothing about allowing medical experimentation.
Vaccination has nothing to do with Nuremberg
code.
This has nothing to do with globalists or
globalism.
This is not anything to do with the new world
order or one world government or anything
like it.
But this is exactly how this stuff spreads.
Think about the chain.
Ursula von der Leyen says countries should
look at mandatory vaccination.
It is then reported on
Speaker 2: falsely, as she's
Speaker 1: saying, get rid of the Nuremberg
code and the next thing you know,
Speaker 2: the EU wants to
Speaker 1: re legalize Nazi medical
Speaker 2: experiments.
Speaker 1: It is how it built.
It's one layer of propaganda
Speaker 2: built on
Speaker 1: another and another and another.
Have they no shame?
No, they have no shame.
But this is about something much, much worse,
and
Speaker 2: I don't expect
Speaker 1: this to end any time soon.
Their claim is the left wants to keep us in
the pandemic forever to control people
Speaker 2: understand that it is
Speaker 1: them
Speaker 2: who in a way benefit from
Speaker 1: the pandemic by being able to get
clicks, by spreading this nonsense day after
day after day.
So don't fall for it.
This is how it spreads,
Speaker 2: and we're going to have more on
Speaker 1: this, including this clip on our
Instagram.
I hope you are following us there at David
Pakman show, and you can also follow me on
Instagram
Speaker 2: at David
Speaker 1: Pakman.
Speaker 2: We'll take a quick break
Speaker 1: and we have plenty more coming
right up.